Щонайменше 10-ть олімпійських медалей
втратила Україна з 2004 року.
Причина - порушення міжнародного антидопінгового кодексу.
У 2019 році Всесвітня антидопінгова агенція WADA
розпочала масштабну перевірку системи допінг-контролю
в Україні під назвою "операція Геркулес".
Антидопінгова перевірка спортсменів здійснюється
шляхом відбору проб під час змагань і в період між змаганнями.
Проби поза змаганнями відбирають так звані допінг-офіцери
- не лише співробітники Національного антидопінгового
центру України, а й фахівці з інших країн.
WADA з'ясувала, що українські функціонери
попереджали спортсменів про допінг-тести та
проводили завчасний забір їхніх зразків в офісах центру.
Виявлені факти - грубе порушення антидопінгового кодексу,
адже тестування спортсменів на допінг
має відбуватися без попередження.
Претензії WADA зводяться до того, що протягом тривалого часу
наш Національний антидопінговий центр
порушував цю вимогу про неінформування спортсменів.
І завчасно інформував спортсменів та тренерів
про проведення таких проб.
З точки зору кодексу WADA, таке порушення є достатньо вагомим
і серйозним. І більше того, як встановило розслідування WADA,
це здійснювалося протягом тривалого часу.
І як написано в звіті - "зухвало".
WADA наводить дані про випадки, коли та чи інша національна команда
в повному складі була присутня в антидопінговому центрі,
чекаючи на тестування. Крім того, WADA встановила,
що перед Олімпіадою в Токіо українська сторона
умисно надала щонайменше шість зразків біоматеріалу спортсменів,
які були взяті під час змагань, вказавши,
що вони були взяті поза змаганнями.
На засіданні в Парижі 24-25 листопада WADA
має намір розглянути попередні результати розслідування
порушень антидопінгового кодексу в Україні
і винести свій вердикт.
Всесвітній антидопінговий кодекс передбачає,
що у разу встановлення порушення, розглядається питання
про відповідність національного антидопінгового центру
через порушення антидопінгового кодексу.
І якщо дії національного антидопінгового центру
визнають такими, що не відповідають кодексу,
то в країні, до якої застосовані санкції,
не можуть проводитися міжнародні змагання.
Результати національних змагань, які відбуваються в цій країні,
не визнаються міжнародними федераціями.
І спортсмени цих країн не можуть брати участь
у міжнародних змаганнях.
При цьому санкції проти окремих спортсменів,
які здобули медалі на чемпіонатах чи олімпіадах, скоріш за все,
не будуть застосовані. Хіба що WADA з'ясує,
що допінгові махінації були здійснені за бажанням
самого спортсмена, або він умисно фальшував проби,
приміром, здавши не свою сечу.
Експерти схиляються до думки, що санкції WADA
поки не поширюватимуться на участь України в зимовій олімпіаді в Пекіні.
А от наступні ігри можуть бути під питанням.
Українські олімпійці та паралімпійці можуть повторити
долю російських атлетів, які через допінговий скандал
виступали на Олімпіаді в Токіо під нейтральним прапором.
До кінця 2022 року Росія не може виступати
під прапором країни на олімпіадах та чемпіонатах.
Водночас експерти вважають, що санкції щодо України
не будуть такими жорсткими, як до Росії,
оскільки український допінговий скандал принципово
відрізняється від російського тим, що у фальшуванні проб росіян
були задіяні спецслужби.
На тлі скандалу керівництво Національного антидопінгового
центру України вже пішло у відставку і наразі нових керівників
ще не призначено. Міністерство спорту запевняє,
що робить усе можливе на перемовинах з WADA,
аби знизити ризик жорстких санкцій.
Не виключно, що спортивні функціонери України
оголосять реформу антидопінгового центру,
можливо, за участі представників WADA.
Організація вже давно ставить під сумнів прозорість центру
хоча б через те, що в наглядовій раді присутні міністри,
депутати Верховної Ради та керівники федерацій,
що є неприйнятним.
Також WADA звертає увагу на те, що при національному центрі
працює лабораторія, яка не має міжнародного сертифікату
і якою можуть зловживати для "корекції" проб спортсменів.
Уже три роки у Верховній Раді припадає пилом законопроєкт
про протидію допінгу, який підготували за участю
експертів Ради Європи. Цей закон передбачає покарання
для недобросовісних спортсменів та тренерів.
В Україні досі немає практики, як у багатьох
демократичних країнах світу, позбавляти спортсмена
та тренера усіх пільг та нагород у разі, якщо їх спіймають на допінгу.